Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Inside
Now we just washed up on a beach and my
throat is feeling a little bit
[beats chest] tested because
I've been recording a lot today in preparation for this
trip, but I think it can hold out
till the end of this game.  SO.
I don't know exactly where we are
I'm getting kind of vibes
from Dishonored.  Do you remember the last
level of Dishonored when he approached
the island?  No spoilers really
but kinda -- that vibe
into the *dark whisper* destitute,
solitary land that it is.
*normal* Not that it's gonna be anything to do with it
BOOSH! BOO! Woah
Woah shit! AARGHH!!
Oh gah-ahd!
Ow!
OW-WWUH!  How are you
alive after that?  You've fallen from
others in different universes
and died, 'cause this is a
multiverse theory, where you've died
a million times over, but
it never seems to have effected.
HURGH! Oh it's too
heavy!  Oh god!
Ok little old me can't do it
so I gotta find
some helpy helperton
to help me along!
I don't know where I'm gonna find a helpy
helperton but -- wooow
[stares in wonder]
What is that?
Woah!
That's HUUUGE!
Well that doesn't
make any sense! This place was a fortress!
How is there just all this stuff?
The structures in this game are just enormous
and -- what is the
THUMPY?
[we observe the confused Markimoo in his silent habitat]
Who the hell is thumpy humpin'?!
That was a complex hump-thump
AND I DON'T APPRECIATE IT!
What is this?  What am I hump-thumpin' here?
This one just doesn't move
Okay
Oh GOD the hump-thumps
are getting more erratic than ever before!
Oh, what does this do?  Is it gonna sh---
19?
[Markimoo.exe processing...]
Oh.
OoOOoooh.
Still wondering about the wumpy
humps!
Yeah that's gone into full-on
Wump Mode
Some'n over here?  Let me put my ear to it!
OH-ho-ho-hooo god!
Ok, so that's bizarre
But apparently that needs
quite a few
able-bodied people
maybe not able-MINDED people but able-bodied
indefinitely.
What does this do?  Heh BLEUGH!
OOH!  We're goin' UUUP!
Okay, I'm yellin' timber!
Or -- I guess I'm going up, I'm
yelling reb-mm
mmit?  Rebmit?
[musically] I'M YELLING REBMIT!
[musically groans]
Okay, anyway...
So what else can we do? Ah.
That doesn't help me at all.
That's probably a return path...
[inhale]
So there's nothing over there...
And there's nothing over here...
Huh.
Okay, now we're onto something.
Daamn, this place so big!
HELLO! HI!
You're part of the collection of people that I need.
Don't mind while I push you off into oblivion!
No?
I can't do--
What am I supposed to do with this?
Can't actually--
Am I supposed to be able to get magical powers that's
gonna to make me command these people on the fly...?
Am I gonna one of those helmets permanently installed into my buh-wain?
Ooh.
I'm okay with that.
The only thing that I'm sad about this series
is that I haven't been able to make nearly as many
dick jokes as I usually enjoy.
'Cuz I mean...
I have a certain standard of--
a quo... a quota!--
A quota of dick quo-- jokes...
Ah, uh.. A dick quota...
A...
Dick-quota.
[chuckles] North Dick-uota...
Ah, South Dick-uota...
DAMN IT!
I could've had that!--
Nevermind... Anyway...
So...
That's just stupidity on my fr--
It's getting very late.
Like I said, I'm recording a lot,
so my mind is a little bit *loopy* then it has been in the past...
Woah.
Hello...
Hi...
Okay...?
There's a rope there...
And I imagine there's probably more people over here...
Can I pull th- I can't pull any of this stuff.
I'm just a child!
[chuckles] How am I supposed to able to do any of this?
Okay, so I can't do that either...
I can't do much of *anything* around here.
I need people.
I mean, I need nineteen more people than I've got...
But I need more people, so...
I need people to be able to help me to do that...
So, I--I... I guess...
The good thing is I'm kind of getting the lay of the land before I actually do it...
And again I don't know what the thumpy-humps are,
but I imagine it's a big whumpy-humperton.
But-- Oooh, what is this?
Hello? AaaaaAAAaah.
Okay...
[inhale]
[exhale]
But I gotta have some method to control these things,
because otherwise, it doesn't mmmean anything...
[the Markimoo is deep in thought]
Hm.
[the Markimoo contemplates life]
M'kay...
Oh, hi...
How you doin'? Okay...
So that's a thing...
So I'm gonna get that, it's gonna fall down,
and then it's gonna be permanently *imbued* inside my buh-wain.
Hopefully.
Slaboosh!
Yes, dive head first into the random, murky waters...
I'm goin' down!
Oh boy, I hope I have enough air for this...
[random groaning sounds]
There we go, okay.
So where do we go now?
Further down?
Can do.
You got it, Bubbs.
You got it, rub-a-dub Bubbs, Bubbs in a tub.
Okay...
Where is this leading?
Woah.
What is that?
Can I climb up this? Yeah, I can...
What *is* that?
[Admires amazing view]
Just fascinated by it more than anything.
Like that's another thing that makes this game really cool.
I'm just kinda fascinated by everything that I see.
Like it's just constantly... really, like...
I--I... It's like I always want to see the next big thing.
I haven't been bored yet at all with the game...
And that's a co--
That's like a quality of a *good* game.
Like solidly good game--
Or good anything, for that matter.
Like good anything to just keeps you engaged,
and makes you want to know more.
HIYAAA!
RAAAAH!!!
I knew it.
I *knew* it!
They caught me!
[chuckles] They caught me!
Cool!
That's awesome! They're gonna come with me now!
Okay...
You come with me, now...
And we're gonna pull a big thing-a-ma-bobber,
and I'm gonna...
Can you get me up here?
Hweh.
Wait. [chuckles]
OoOOOoh!
I pray to the heavens!
Save us!-- Okay...
Hey-uhp!
Okay...
Woop-dibby-woop!
Thank you! Man, these guys are good.
I have *truly* become Control Master.
It's like when in, uh, the original Limbo, when that...
When the worm got in your brain,
and things ain't do so good am done...
Alright, so...
[random Markimoo sounds]
But this is a little bit better because now I have super powers.
I imagine for permanencies.
Aw, c'mon! Be careful, man.
You're gonna get caught up in things.
Aw, they're so creepy!
I was about to say 'adorable,' but it's just really bizarre
the way that they [giggles] kinda mash up against me.
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
They're just so...
Aw, they just wanna serve.
That's so... nice, I suppose.
Not really, but... we're gonna go pull a thing.
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Come with me, we got more work to do!
I'm gonna call you...
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, Marshall...
(so original Mark, wow.)
...and Vladimir.
He's in the back.
He's a little slower then the rest, but that doesn't matter.
So Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, Marshall, and *Vladimir*
You guys come and help me pull big ol' honkin' thing.
Ho!
Ho!!
Ho!!!
Don't [phlegm] look at me!
Vladimir, get in there!
Wow.
Ooh.
Phew!
Phew!!
[horse noise]
I know, I know, I know...
Okay, so what...
(How do the Markimoo do?)
(That is how the Markimoo do.)
Okay, I'm going to leave that there.
And then I'm gonna get them to pull me up on this thing...
Vladimir, get back here!
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall are always so good.
And like, ready to go whenever I need them to.
But you have not been meeting expectations...
Vladimir: (´꒳`∗)
So wait a minute...
Aah, there we go. Okay...
Sooo...
What does this mean?--
Oooh, I get it.
I need to... ffff--
--fill it with something...?
Oh, what is that out there?
Oh, man...
So I need to fill it, or I need to get inside of it...
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Hey!
Did you guys push that back?
Why'd you push that back?!
[Markimoo.exe thinking...]
Do I gotta...
[Markimoo.exe STILL thinking...]
What do I gotta do here--
I-I'm guessing it rolled back so I guess I gotta..
..pull this really far then quickly--
[Inhales]
--get up in that THING..
And then do the thing..?
[THUMP]
Alright--hurry hurry hurry!
K let me up--let me up up..
..up
Uuuuppp.. Ok
Wait it's not moving??
Then why did it move?
Why did it move from where it was before?
[...]
Oh 'cause they're PUSHING it!
Their literally walking it over.
Ohhh ok.
Ahhh that makes sensssee.
Come to mee Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, Marshall and *Vladimir*
Ook, I get it now
I--[Laughs] am the smart one
HABOOSKI!
Ok.
So with all my "Haboofki Powers"
I'ma gonna go somewhere..
..can I get up this?
Thank you.
Awe they're gonna be so lost without me... :(
They're gonna be so scare-wouD
I don't want them to scare-wouD about me--
I hope this doesn't ruin it..
[Splish Splash]
..by getting water on this, reeaally bizarre mind control device doesn't do anything bad for me.
Yeah..
So far so good--
--AHH!
Hello.
Why are you up there?
How did you get up there..?
Let me boost this out of the way.
This is gonna be a Heumpy-Dump
Oh it's gonna be a--
--oh it's gonna Heump me so goood! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
[Markimoo mating call..?]
[..Epic fail..]
That did nothing.
That did NOTHING!
Hey you guys, you lazy assbags get out of there!
[Such a good comeback Mark -.-]
Maybe if i'm not standing on it, it'll be a little bit better..
[2nd Attempt]
Heh..
Ehhh--NOPE that ain't it!
So wait a minute..
..somethings..
..something's funky.
Maybe I gotta pull this box on it..?
I don't know why that would be a thing..
So lets try it.. [So much doubt]
GO FOR GOLD!
[Markimoo.exe struggles]
That's a heavy ass box! ;-;
Okayy..??
Maybe if I'm standing--
--maybe I'm standing I gonna break this thing.
If I...
..pull this,
put this on here,
stand on the box--
--LETS GO FOR GOLD!
[3rd Attempt]
[Broken Markimoo]
That--
--that sucked..
Oh I know what I need to do!
I need to..
..lanch it THEN put the box underNEATH it,
it'll break the box.
Hehehehe!
*Lisp* Whose the smart one now?!
Oh..
UhhhAhhUhhh...
Hu-huhahaha.. Haaaaa
HahahHA!
[Markimoo becomes Santa Claus?]
Hehe--AHHH!
DON'T FALL ON ME!
Oh good thing they avoided me
they're so good at what they do.
Yeah..
They must have some semblance of autonomy if they can get up on their own.
Its gotta be a thing they can do--
Come along! I don't have the patience to name all of you or the memory with which to remember them.
John,
Jeffrey,
Jameson.
John, Jeffrey, Jameson,
Jeffrey, Billy Sam--
--oh I already named Jeffrey.
John..
John, JACOB,
Jameson.
John, Jacob, Jameson... Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall.
John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshall.
Andd Vladimir, I can't forget about Vladimir
Vladimir is my...
UH biologically related son andd I have proof for that or else I wouldn't believe it.. -.-'
But J-Jeffrey, Jacob, Jamison
No no..
[Mark just stop...]
John, Jacob, Jameson..
John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshall.
This is not very important.
[chuckles] Why am I worrying about these stupid ass names?
"Oh I don't know, I don't know!"
I make tasks for myself to keep my memory engaged..
Throw me!
Horra-
HUZZAH!
HuZZAH!!
[chuckles]
Alright thank you John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall
Okay, do I need to go..
..uuupp?
No I can--I can lift the door to the left firssstt
Then I can go up, get those guys on the right...
Or maybe they can launch me up above..?
Maybe that's a thing they could do..
Because they must have some self-preservation thing because they're obviously not gonna..
[Inhales]
They're not gonna do anything that's gonna like actually kill them so they kinda just do their own thing
until they get to a point where they can no longer do that thing.. Right?
Isn't that right John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffrey, Billy Samwise, and Marshall, and Vladimir..?
Vladimir's still in the back I know he's there.
Alright.
Whoever you is, you're going to join our party.
Gonna be fun on a bun. 〜(￣▽￣〜)(〜￣▽￣)〜
BU-BRAH! [chuckles]
So many of us..
Hey!
How's it going?
Join us.
Jooin us.
One of us. [chuckles]
One of us!
Ok.
Can you guys...?
Launch me!
Eeeeahthat dun! Made it!
I did not think that I was gonna make it. :o
bu-wOah
Tha-tha-that's weird.
[chuckles] Why were you in that cart?
WHY WERE YOU GUYS???
So I gotta criss cross this
[chuckles] But they're not having a fun ride
they're very upset about this
But I gotta criss cross this
and they have enough momentum to--
AH FUUCK
that probably hurt SORRY
SORRY BOYS
It's probably that light
[sounds of Markiplier groaning]
[more sounds of Markiplier groaning but more intense]
[even more intense groaning]
Ah shit very close
ALMOST GOT IT BOYS
ALMOST GOT IT x2
Don't worry about it
uuuhhhHHHOHO GGOODD
I'm not gonna name you assholes >:(
[whispers] I'm probably gonna name those assholes
YA BOOPEE
I did it!
WHEEEEEEEEEEEE-
agh
HA [fart noise] they're all dead ok
So we got
John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, Marshall, and Vladimir
I'm gonna name you
Was there th-three of them
Um
Larry, Mo, and Curly
Just to make it easy on us
We got Larry, Mo, Curly, John, Jacob, Jameson
Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall
, and Vladimir
[chuckles] We can't forget about Vladimir
[repeats the names to himself again]
COME WITH ME BOYS
Oh man, I didn't know I was going to be such a
an involved adoptive father for all of you guys <3
[repeats the names again omg]
Can't forget about Vladimir
Oh god I hope I don't have to name anymore of these assholes
I'm not going to be able to do it :'(
My brain has a limited /CAPACITY/
for names
I can't even remember names of people that I /meet/
So how can I remember the names of
[repeats the names (Mark please stop)]
Alright so we're almost there
We just need to go up a little farther
And YOU assholes are going to help me LAUNCH
into another area
Now was there anybody to the left
I can't remember if there was anybody to the left
Might as well go check!
Come on
Curly, John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, aaannnd Marshall
(He forgot Vladimir)
Anybody over here?
AUUUAHHH
There ARREEEE
So if we push you off
What's that gonna-
Oh that's-
This is not gonna end well
SORRY
[Mark screaming for the children]
[sound of cage crashing]
[Mark's cringing face]
That sounded bad :(
[Mark's still cringing]
I don't think they survived that
I don't know how they /could/
(all his childrens' names) ARE MURDERERS
They're GOSHDARN BLOODY MURDERERS
I can't believe it
Ok so
You guys grab onto me
Don't fail me please
No
No no no no no
Alright come on
Come on
Don't be silly bitches
[gibberish noises]
Ok
Thank you <3
Wait for me
[All the names again except for Vladimir]
Are you alive?
No you're dead
You're vu-ary deead
So what do we got here
Wuah shit
I don't know what keeps thumpin on that yumper
No wonder everybody abandoned this place
Wait so there's no point of coming up here then
That one's dead
You ok?
Oh
[sound of Mark's epiphany]
Maybe
[Mark realizing the situation again]
We don't need a live body
We don't need live bodies
Oh that's sad :(
It's sad that the kid understands the reality of this situation
Oh man
Maybe those other guys died and we just gotta drag
their limp dead bodies
[Markimoo groaning at the fact in disgust]
ARE THEY EVEN ALIVE THAT'S ANOTHER QUESTION
Are they even considered alive creatures
I mean to me
Larry, Mo, Curly, John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall, and Vladimir
Maybe not Vladimir but
You know, the-they're-they mean a lot to me
I get them <3
Oh they're dead :(
Oh yep, they're... they're
OOH
[chuckling] Whaaaatt???
HOW DID YOU SURVIVE THAT???
Holy crap you guys are strraanng
My goodness
Alright
So
Whew
[Mark's back at it again]
Richard, Rick, Randy
Larry, Mo, Curly,  John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, Marshall, and Vladimir
Richard, Rick, Randy- no
Richard, Rick, Randy?
[repeating the names... again]
Ok
HUH
Ok, so Richard, Rick, Randy
Larry, Mo, Curly, John, Jacob, Jameson, Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, Marshall, and Vladimir
COME WITH ME!!!
COME WITH ME
FOLLOW ME!!!
Oh they're not following me
Alright, bye boys! :)
Bye Richard, Rick, Randy-
WoooahhhhHH shit
What is that?
What IS that?
Hooly SHIT BALLS
WOoooahh
It's NUTS
What is that that's so cool!
Oh god
[Markimoo screaming in fear]
I should've done better
uehahheuhhuhh
Oh my god
That is insanity, that's so cool!
WhAat is that?
What's doing that? It's so cool I luv it! <3
Oh shit.
Eoodo dee dee dee dee dee dee deedeedee dee DEEUGH
Good th-
thing they have s-th-
OH hello.
It's good thing they have things set up like this. It's very helpful.
HEBEWUA okai
AWe man im gonna miss Ri-Richard, Rick, Randy, John, Jacob, Jameson, Larry, Mo, Curly, Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, and marrrrrrshall (forgot Vladimer)
They were mah best boys.
What are YOU doing?
Man, why would anyone even bother making
machinery in this area?
Ok, so I gotta time this
-no.  I gotta stop this
riiiight
...yyyyyYYYYONDER!
ok
Well that gives me enough time to climb up a bit
Cause apparently that- that pulse is gonna
blast the liquid off of mah bones
but only the liquid
Literally only the liquid.
Oh boy..
ok
Here we go!
I gotta find what's gonna happen when that happens
but- Oh god
AHHHHHHHH
IT BLAAASTED THE LIQUID OFF OF MAH BONNNES!  D:
I didn't know that that was gonna happen that way,
but wooow!
Ok,
so I could do this differently.
So we're gonna-
UUEEGH
That bad.
OOOOH that bad.
oKAY
So I gotta figure out another way to do this.
So if I...
Crank the yank there
like usual.
Get by here
HubaDOOP
Now I'm super intrigued-
Now I am incredibly intrigued
as to what in the HELL
is going on is going on in this world.
It is SO cool
Ok, so there's no other way to go down this except...
Oh.
Hahoh
That was a close one.
So there's no other way to get down this except for...
utilizing this thing
so
MAYBE I could make it all up in one chunk
But that NEEDS to be there
I don't think I could make it all the way up the ladder
without it.
Maybe I can plan for it.
ok
I'm plannin' for it!
HeheheheYEAHahahah
Ok, that'll work
ooooh.
*Tone of music changes*
Ok.
Yeah, the music is confirming that I did something relatively smart.
Ok, so by the time I get down there it should be another blockade.
*laughs maniacally*
Don't try to hit me, debris,
I've got mah BRAIN juice flowin'
Ok, so
I have to time this.
So I'm gonna crank that
Then-
YEAAAAAH
there we go
There we go
THERE WE GO
I'm gettin' it!
I know what I'm doing
YEAAAH :D
What does this do?
haBLEEUGH!
Oh, that's-
NO
Oh god!
Oh- I'm sorry!
EEUUUH I'M SORRY!
wait.
Oh, those things aren't real.
Those are test dummies or something.
...ok, we're fine.
Oooh, that guy got flown.
That guy got FLEWED
SHIT!
aaaAAAGGGHHHhhh!!!
I got blasted.
Ok, so,
Why did I open those windows?
'Did those windows NEED to be open?' is the question.
Maybe I can drag THIS with me?
OH ok I can drag this with me
Ok, that's good.
This is awfully handy
I LEIK THIS.
Ok, so...
That's as far as it goes right there...
Oh WOW.
Hello.
Man, it's so fascinating
WHOA
DID NOT KNOW THAT WAS THAT HOW THAT WORKED
OHOHOKAY
I did not-
ok...
alright. ok.
Alright.  Ok. *pitch increases*
*pitch intensifies* ALRIGHT.  OK
ARKAY
..So.
I should've payed attention to the railing as more than just a guide
It was a brace.
Ok, so...
Gonna hold this right here
Little here..
HABOINK!
ok.  Now we're gonna
go go go go go go go go go go
eeeEEEUGH!!!
AAAAAAGHAHA
Ohoho.
Very close on you.
HALLO!
Wow, okay
You need to be a little more protective of me
You're being a bit of a douche
alright so, what is this thing?
What kind of purpose is this? It's not even grabbing anything
Okay, I think I go down. I go down. It's gonna go down right about
Here
Ugh, okay
Go, go, go. Go, go, goo.
Yeah!
Okay, goodbye.
Ahhh, no! Oh god
I forgot that it was going to do that thing
I was that close to the end
I'm a fuckbag
I'm bag of fuck
Oooh hey
Okay
*utter concentration*
Wait so, I don't need to...
I'm not trying to
Ah shit shit shit shit shit
Shit! Ah fuck I was so close
okay so I just need to drop down
Right as the pulse is going, but I was trying not to go back
So I knew what I needed to do just wasn't able to do it
HABOOSHKY
And
HABOOFKY
okay
And
HABOOFKY
Okay, so we're good, we're good, we're good, and we're good. Okay
Man this poor kid
What this kid has had to endure
And it's like so electromagnetic pulse as well
Like who- who would build machinery here?
Oh I think we're out of it
Think we're officially out of it, okay this is good
Man, who would build anything out here?
Unless that wasn't here to begin with but then why would stuff still be running?
Why would they still have
Like this quote unquote personnel zombie mannequin type people
I don't know. There's so many questions and Idon't have any answers
Good? Bad?
Goodbad?
Badgood?
I have no idea
Goodbad maybe bad maybe good
How far down can we go?
Uh-oh, well that ain't good
Ahh damn it
Ahhh damnit
Ahhh-oh that's not good
How do I get out of here?
Through here? Left?
Oh boy, oh boy. How do I get out of here?
How do I get out of here? How do I get out of here?
There's really no option
How do I get- ooooh opening that
going, going, going, going
See the light, go towards the light
Light is good, light is good. Okay
Well that was saving grace for this kid
If that wasn't there he would have been utterly bonerowned
Man I want to know what that energy source is
Want to know so badly
I want to know!
We're going to find out in the next episode
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
and as always I will see you
In the next video
Buh bye!
*badass soundtrack*